[Music]
don't sneeze it's not a sneeze song have
you [ __ ] on one today my dude yeah
yeah up top oh yeah
where'd you get this shirt stitch fix oh
if you didn't even get it at Citrix guys
Citrix is a great service you can get
some really stylish clothing from really
expensive brands for not expensive
prices stitch fix is a really awesome
service that you can start right now by
going to the stitch fix sorry just
stitch fix calm slash n Julian that's a
stitch fix calm slash and really get an
extra 25% off when you keep everything
in your box it's pretty dope ok check it
out also guys while you're at it if you
want to build a website Squarespace is
the way to do it Squarespace lets you
create edit and design your website to
be as beautiful as you'd imagined it and
it's very easy they have amazing
customer support go to squarespace.com
slash jena Julian save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain or
give it a shot with a free trial it is a
really fun thing to do whether it's for
business or her hobby whatever building
a website just became cool with
Squarespace also this skin isn't what is
he doing it is a completely free
newsletter that shows up in your email
inbox and gives you all the bullet
points of what's going on in the world
without any of the fluff go to the skim
th es que IM m comm slash annejulien you
subscribe by entering your email and
that's it it's completely free I use it
I love it is one of the things in my
email inbox that I don't loathe and
you're also entered to win a $250 Visa
gift card when you sign up for the skim
today why you have two little Raptors
scratching it either side of your leg
right now are getting attacked from all
angles let's play a game let's just see
how long they go at it like you're not
gonna give in so let's just see how long
they're still going firm standing here
peach keeps pretending like she's gonna
jump up every week yeah let's see let's
see if they go get the daddy told y'all
the lane yep
money's having some naked time right now
we took off her collars so she looks
like a giraffe hey no Carlmont spawned
me in a circle and she can jump on top
the carpets from your chair yeah cuz
he's kicking me Cait straight up bullies
you I know that's like a but he's a
bully he bullies me he takes my lunch
money and he beats me up and he
scratches you every single day yeah he
doesn't apologize oh he doesn't care
about me and then he licks you yeah he's
tormenting you these psychological games
it's hard are you okay I don't know do
you want to go to a different school
he's a scary bully he is a scary bully
have you seen him well he's a rat in
your bed right now please we had we had
like a little little get-together
yesterday for the Super Bowl and the
whole time cream I cried the whole time
yeah I mean we had we had got we had
gotten him out he had food I mean we had
a lot of dog time before anyone came
over but when people came over he just
was crying to the scream crying and he
demanded to be held and when we put him
down he cried mm-hmm and then he would
beg people he was just like we had to go
bad we had to bust out the sling so like
marble has a little sling that I carry
him in and if Kermit's being like really
cry upset it's not a word right put him
in there and then he stops crying like
he needs to be held it's insane
yeah and what's funny is I mean we've
talked about a million times how he's
the worst in the house but the best when
we take him out in the world but we had
our trainers over Dustin and Carolyn
they came over to watch the game with us
and we've brought Kermit to the gym
before and he's so good and they've seen
him there and he's like so well-behaved
there he like sits and he waits and he
doesn't cry yeah he's fine happy and so
when they saw him like completely being
a nuisance and a little baby they're
like what what's going on here and we're
like yeah he's two dogs that he's home
Kermit and he's world Kermit
Kermit out of your home Kermit Kermit
you're being a real home carbon out here
your home Kermit you know go we should
just make one episode we should just
make the entire green screen his his
face just okay what picture of his face
I don't know let's decide I mean there's
a lot of there's um there's this the the
screen grab from the zoom in on him that
people use you know when he like turns
the camera as i zoom in onto him and
he's just like there's that one and then
there's a billion others he's literally
scratching at Gina's arm right now this
is a fun experiment it's okay I'm sorry
you're getting bullied okay when we were
watching the Super Bowl - we bunny
really wanted to be on the couch so we
all had to take up like enough space on
the couch because she kept trying to
like slip her little pointy face in
there and get up on the couch it she
like chased you at one point to try it
she only tried to race you to the couch
bunny had potentially she had her best
day ever yesterday ever she's good with
people and dogs but yesterday we kind of
learned that she loves the attention
when we have cast it up she hams it up
she shows off it's like the way peach
Inkerman 20 ever guessed you know once
the you know the guests kind of settled
in and they've said hi and everything
they'll just start chasing each other on
the couch to show up I'll play with a
toy bunny did that yesterday and it was
probably the cutest she's ever been like
we literally we didn't want to let her
on the couch because there were so many
people and we just we're not gonna have
you claimed the couch today bunny we
have a lot of people for you know you
can sit in your bed and she knew that we
were trying to like block her so me and
her like we kind of looked at each other
being bunny and then I like sprinted
towards the castle like to like block
that open spot she raced me there on the
carpet and she also laid on her back for
the first time she laid on her back for
the first ever she was just on the couch
she had never laid on her back like
roached you know waiting for her
you see that she was just on the couch
and I went up to her and she like leaned
over and looked at her leg for pets and
I just kind of like moved her a little
bit and she like kind of rolled with it
and then ended up on her back like this
first time we've ever seen her on her
but we have a picture I should post it
but she's fully on her back and like
smiling and like just hamming it up and
there were guests I mean it was it was
incredible to watch her just like
perform for the guests so funny yeah
that's fine girl but she's she had a
really good day today we've been walking
her pretty much every single day so
she's really thriving with the walks and
I'm like carmit screaming still do you
like my outfit Julianne yeah what's
going on I'm I'm wearing Oliver Peck
cosplay Juhu Oliver Peck is the tattoo
guy not just the tattoo guy Oh tattoo
guy oh the ink masters tattoo guy yeah
do you know what you win when you ain't
winning masters oh [ __ ] dude you get a
feature in Inked Magazine that is did
you [ __ ] you in [ __ ] ink I want to
eat masters you guys been the one ink
master tattoo no I've never done in
tattoo in my life but I'm getting a
feature in Inked Magazine are you
excited
top-4 that segue the connor high five
yes I'm very excited so we're gonna be
an ink magazine I mean you didn't even
have to win ink master
that's a funny ass joke our trainers had
that mm-hmm
well we're winding a bit I'm doing I did
a photo shoot for a magazine where they
were like doing a profile on me it's
like a feature piece it's very cool and
I was very honored that they wanted to
do that and I'll talk a little bit about
it but I told one of our friends and I
was like yeah like I'm doing this photo
shoot and it's for anchor magazine and
he was like damn you don't even have to
winning bastards and has like I don't
even think about that that's so funny
because we used to watch that show and
the big prize was like you know a chunk
of money but then the main thing that
people were psyched about was the
feature in a magazine and I was like
you're right I didn't have to I need not
that winning blasters and I got the
feature dude
hey no no we're playing it he's being
really persistent No
Oh daddy said no Oh daddy said no uh-oh
so what they do is tell us Julian my
first question when you came home was
did they take a picture of your chair
no they I catchment kept most of my
clothes on no they didn't see you my
upper thigh tattoo or my rib tattoo but
what else what else what should I get a
butt tattoo uh no um well yeah shave
your butt what you don't like my hairy
butt no but you have to shave any area
of skin that you're gonna tattoo right
depends well yeah you gonna shave you
butt
okay okay well thanks for listening guys
that's it shaver but I just want him
scratching you to be on on the podcast
all the time stop scratching he's
bullying me
no we did a photo shoot in this like
kitchen set it was like a fake kitchen
that's so fun and um it was it was like
mainly showcasing like my sleeve tattoos
my arms and stuff and it was really fun
and I spent just over like a month
trying to get in like good shape cuz I
was gonna be in a photo shoot and it was
like it was an exciting start to finish
process and it comes out in a couple
months I'm allowed to talk about it
which is why were talking about it I
didn't realize until recently but you
know I worked with this awesome
photographer his name was Troy and we it
was actually cool cuz we had me like
flipping some food in a pan to get some
photos and I was kind of like describing
to him like you know what I do and he
was like so you're like a chef on
YouTube and I was like well no I mean
the lectures of Minecraft cake
chef and I was like flattered but I also
was like explaining to him that like you
know my my content is not because I'm
good at cooking it's because I've just
do things and like
experiment and people like to watch my
failures and little triumphs and
whatever and he was like I think that's
really cool interesting dietary
restriction yeah true true and he was
like so do you you don't ever mess up
alright and I was like no I mess up all
the time and he was like oh that's
really cool like he thought that was
cool so then he was like ok I have an
idea
and so he had this spray which I didn't
know existed but it's like a smoke spray
it's made of like some sort of water
compound but it's photographers use it
and they spray the air and you can
barely see it when you're in the room
you're like I don't even know he just
did the picture on camera with the
lights it looks like smoke oh it's so
fun so he made it we made this like sort
of scene where I was like burning down
the kitchen there was like smoke coming
out from behind me I think what an Aries
photograph it was it was on brand for
sure can I pick him up yeah he's
screaming no no well you're holding
strong we are not letting him get up
here so yeah we took some photos and
then uh then we stopped and I went home
and we'll see how it turns out we said
should be cool shouts out ink magazine
he's really cool to have them offer I
had done one thing with them before
where I did a video and it just feels so
[ __ ] rad to be you know involved in
the tattoo community like that because
I'm such a fan of them like yeah tattoo
world so you know I'm just upset they
didn't take a standalone picture of your
chair well we can always take one and
send it to him see if it'll make think I
want to open up a magazine and just see
a tattoo of a chair you know have a seat
show me your chair well I talked about
it what did you say I said sometimes you
just go get a chair tattooed on your leg
at 11:00 p.m. and and then I was like
now I can just look at Jenna and say
have a seat which is pretty much like
one of my favorite tattoos of yours why
got it cuz it's funny
yeah funny judges are fun I think
they're so funny I kind of want to get
like more derpy tattoos on my leg you
gonna make a hole derp leg yeah why not
make it there Plex Dylan is a two-legged
Ripley he does a vittoria leg yeah why
don't you tell them what a toy leg is
sorry friend Dylan he tours to to play
music and so he dedicated one of his
legs
to get tattoos only when he's on tour in
random locations yeah you know across
the world or whatever so every tattoo on
that leg is from somewhere on his tour
which i think is a really dope idea so I
just have a derp leg I do it all locally
I don't travel for any of it but it's
none of its cool what else would you get
oh yeah what do you already have like a
vacuum cleaner a chair yeah you know
what's fun is kitchen utensils what if
you just get a picture of all household
items I knew I would totally get more
household items I would get uh can I
please pick him up he's screaming oh no
what do you guys think
they said you give me one you're the one
that's always so upset about the audio
in the podcast is just a screaming
Kermit he's just stop truly the worst
you've been on your worst behavior
lately what's with you
no but I was thinking so I posted this
picture without a shirt on which you
know patreon only but in the picture you
can see tattoos that I'm pretty sure
I've never shown anyone like what well
the vacuum cleaner I don't think I ever
posted oh and then you had sort of just
a better view of some of the tattoos I
don't really post about and um it
reminded me that this this article and
this feature is gonna be cool for people
who who maybe watch me in like wanna
know about my tattoos because people ask
me all the time like every day tell us
more about you so you did like an
interview too or you talked about what
all your tattoos yeah I went through
every single tattoo I have and I
described what it is and what the
meaning behind it is and who did it and
when I got it so if you're interested in
like my tattoo collection and I I know I
haven't really been thorough about it
you'll think it'll be cool for people to
get a chance to see the tattoo
explanations but yeah I forget where I
was going with that but yeah those yeah
the vacuum cleaner so I have a vacuum
cleaner on my forum and I would
definitely get more household appliances
what do you think like a blender like I
guess stand mixer it was a joke no no
I'm trying to piece together what this
would look like you're gonna make a derp
leg you got to put derpy stuff on there
how about
that little shelf and no that [ __ ] that
little table no ok bookshelf a book ok
ok what book
shredder a paper shredder what book
should get attached with a little tiny
book that's it that's good when you're
bored you can sit in your chair and read
a book how about one pages on the inner
right oh my god right no why
okay that is folder plague magazine
cover no like you have like an actual
like scale sized piece of paper on your
leg tattooed on each leg as if you had
like a book open on your leg no you're
just right on the page or something
tattooed the book okay that's good idea
I'm all ears for tattoo ideas I mean I
think you guys know that I know if you
have something you think I should get
just let me know I don't put it on my
body I'm already getting the twist logo
tattooed the koala to it that's right
okay that is so cute though
mm-hmm yeah we raised some money for
Australia and I told you guys who helped
raise it that if we got to $25,000 I
would get a tattoo of your choosing and
they decided they designed it and they
decided right it's like a it's a koala
bear mixed with a twitch logo it's
literally the twitch logo with koala
years yeah my guys guys it's so cute
it's really cute where are you getting
it I need forehead
oh my elbow Ana's gonna do it she's
gonna forehead why not my forehead yeah
I'll think about it
why just get the word Drake tattooed on
your forehead like that one girl that's
not all she got that dude was she a
tattooed didn't she it wasn't it
something dirty about Drake I just said
the word Drake no there was one girl
that got the tattoo that was like some
celebrity and then something dirty you
know what I'm talking about
what is it I don't somebody remind me
what is it there was like maybe not I
thought it was like a celebrity in them
like I don't know something
not-safe-for-work tattooed on their face
can I see your fingernails yeah why do
you paint your fingernails and then
immediately pick off all the nail polish
I feel attacked you don't do a base coat
or a top coat you actually don't black
on actually you actually not you just
paint on like two days actually hi
actually I do do a base coat do you want
to know which one
hollow taco yeah hollow taco pili base
coat because they're fun the peel that's
why you've been peeling off your nail
Paul
yes peel the base coat is amazing
because then it comes off in like a
couple pieces and it's like it's like
peeling an orange and it's pili and then
I just paint him again but I use the
base coat
Anna taco so back off lady why do you
pay your nails so lunch you could just
you could do it once and then leave it
but I have anxiety if you like what do
you want from me I enjoy the way my
fingers looked when they're painted
uh-huh but I can't not pick them okay
that's the end of the story I got it why
don't you why don't you paint and pick
your nails I don't feel like pain okay
cuz I'd rather take a nap so talk to us
about this cosplay well I put a jacket
on over pajamas why is why is that a
cosplay that's just an outfit this from
the top up with this hat and this hair
in this shirt I look like Oliver Peck
gonna do if I had one tell me my tattoo
sucks see what you did there man you
packed in the color and they're real
nice but the outline dude just ruins it
oh you need a toothpick that just said
that just said that
yeah it's kinda too thick in my mouth
you didn't say I thought I just said
that did you I don't know you say it out
loud yes oh did you text me I didn't
text I don't think you hurt I don't
think I heard you say it did you say it
I said it maybe not
anyway we look really good if you had a
toothpick
give me a toothpick I'm gonna run
downstairs no okay let's just Photoshop
give me something to put in my mouth
here no this is filthy phones are dirty
don't put them in your mouth okay well I
kissed Kermit I put lots of filthy
things in my mouth now your phones are
so dirty
don't don't like them carrots filthy Oh
are you happy now by the if he's gonna
be the background we have to hold him up
in front of how's it look guys see it
because it's not post yet no we can see
it there is did you have fun watching
the Super Bowl though yesterday I did I
had a really good time watching
JLo and Shakira I thought it was that
was a good show so wonderful and so fun
and if your opinion is different than
mine I respect yours but I thought it
was so entertaining and such a good time
and I loved it and I thought it was one
of the better halftime shows we've had
didn't in a little while yeah totally I
agree against maroon 5 and Elena but I
was bored to tears by their halftime
performance Lady Gaga's was incredible
incredible we watched it last night
actually yeah Bruno Mars was incredible
Beyonce like obviously there's been some
really good ones but it was nice to have
such a fun dance filled choreography
great music just a great time just a
great living legends and Shakira so
overqualified for that and she did the
World Cup like 10 years ago and she's
just another days another day's work for
her she's just such a legend like
literally when I was in fourth grade and
I was in Spanish class we would listen
to Shakira music in Spanish to help us
understand Spanish that's so cool she's
she's been making music for like my
whole life yeah and she's just fantastic
she killed it she killed it I mean JLo
is 50 years old and it's just absolutely
insane insane she's unbelievable
she's unbelievable yeah I'll tell her
next time I see her [ __ ] so so mad that
you ever got to be in the same room as
her how dare you oh she's a pal yeah
really I just came home I was like what
she [ __ ] smelled like it she's not oh
my [ __ ] god we drive like a [ __ ] beat
she yeah that was a really great show we
learned that secures hips kind of lie
though the kind of life there
what are you even saying well they don't
lie but they kind of lie what are you
talking about we're talking about her
outfit and how it emphasizes the
movement and it's like it's almost like
it's just interesting because I didn't
well in like in any culture where
there's big belly dancing so you'd like
hula skirts or like Polynesian you know
she's from Colombia there's like if
you're wearing a skirt with like fringe
or something around your hips with
movement like a skirt that's flowy yeah
it'll make all those movements look a
lot bigger pronounced that's all I was
saying to you I didn't say her hips a
lot
I said her hips slide you're put that
sent this back it's a joke because we
all know her hips don't lie but they're
a little bit her hips you know perps
just stop leave him alone stop him
what do you think about the Super Bowl
guy what why'd you just grab him he was
sitting comfortably he absolutely wasn't
he was readjusting like every five
seconds I feel like he does a survival
thing when you pick up marble he's like
something something in his walnut brain
is telling him I'm very high in the air
right now
I should stay as still as possible is
that thing what freezing it's like as a
defense mechanism in the wild yes
absolutely I feel like it's a defense
mechanism to protect himself he doesn't
like wiggle around once you pick him a
high but yeah I think I think a lot of
animals who have predators
me I'm holding him so wonderfully have
you ever seen someone hold the dog so
wonderfully ready animals that have a
lot of predators definitely freeze
sometimes no we're talking about when
you pick him up yeah but if a predator
tried to pick up marble he would be
screaming and fighting well then he
knows I'm not a predator
right I don't know you whisper I'm a
predator at him for all the time I got
behind him and I whisper into his neck
I'm a predator yeah I'm like Julian stop
it's the hub I don't know what that
predator means
what if he does he doesn't they're okay
the five words he knows one of them is
not predator what does he know you wanna
that's one you wanna that's one word see
that's the other word his name ma boo
chicken Vicky that's the other word and
I don't think I don't think sit or up
are in his vocab I think they were at
one point with her what about high I
think high is all right oh yeah hi hi
walk oh he likes walk yeah he's a slow
man it's like walking a tortoise I'm
straight
but it's not that he can he walk slow
like he can walk perfectly fine yeah
he's just you know a hyper a little low
male boy that needs to stop every one
foot to smell in pee on everything
mm-hmm
so it's therefore very slow to walk it
that's that's very because he does not
care if we keep him moving he does not
want to keep him moving
yeah and he's got a built-in coat when
the others are always naked mm-hmm did
you get your coat from stitch fix though
Wow Julian what's your style why are you
holding him like that adventures
sophisticated simple however your style
is stitch fix can help you elevate it
Citrix is an online personal styling
service that finds and delivers clothes
shoes and accessories that fit your body
budget and lifestyle it's a pretty great
service when you go to stitch fixed comm
flash energy line you tell them your
size your style preferences and how much
you want to spend on each item there's
no subscription required right so if you
want to just do it once you can and what
they do is they formulate a box of
clothing specifically for you and then
they send it to your house in a box
right a stylist put it together someone
who's qualified to which is very cool
you try them on at home no pressure you
can do it you know as slow or as fast as
you want you can turn on music if you
want you can keep it quiet
and you see how everything fits and you
only pay for what you love so if you
don't like something you send it back
shipping is free exchanges or free
returns are always free and their
styling fee is only twenty dollars which
is applied towards anything you keep
from your shipment very cool service
check it out by going to stitch fix comm
slash colonel julyan get an extra 25%
off when you keep everything in your box
or hit the link down below
speaking of links you can build your own
website with Squarespace right now by
going to squarespace.com slash Jen and
Jillian Squarespace is how you make
websites look very good and have an easy
time doing it if you have a small
business if you have photography blog
that you want to turn in a website if
you have needs for an online store for
your merchandise whatever it is
Squarespace helps you do it wow I'm all
over the place today it's a really
awesome platform basically it's a
drag-and-drop visual website builder
with an editor built-in and 24 hours a
day 7 days a week customer service so if
it wasn't easy enough you have them to
hold your hand if you need someone to
hold your hand they'll hold your hand 24
hours a day they will see that the
customer service is on point it helps
you with any sort of snags you might run
into when building a website because you
might not have built a website before
but Squarespace makes it very easy and
they help you make it exactly how you
envision it to be and make it look good
on mobile on desktop whatever you guys
are concerned about Squarespace is there
to help you make beautiful so go to
squarespace.com slash annejulien save
10% when you purchase your first website
or domain or you can give it a free
trial and that's completely free so
check it out and lastly guys the skin
over 7 million people wake up to news
that is summarized beautifully and
concisely with this skin is a newsletter
that you subscribe to completely for
free comes in your email inbox and you
get to read it digest it and then you're
done
then you're smarter you're more
knowledgeable and you can go on
throughout your day and just know things
so the skin makes it easy for you in
about five minutes to like ingest all
the important information you should
have at the start of the day going into
the world it helps you and it's
completely free you can also deep dive
on
the topics maybe like money or career or
health and the skin offers a guide to
help you dig deeper in any of those
topics that you're interested in check
them out we're going to the skim that's
th es ki mm - MS hamsa la Serna Julian
you go there you type in your email like
that completely free hit subscribe and
when you do that with our URL you were
entered to win potentially a $250 Visa
gift card thank you to our sponsors
thank you sponsors why do I have to he's
so cute
you don't think he's so cute he's okay
you know when you look at someone and
you're like man they're attractive you
know and then they open their mouth and
you're like nope that's what sometimes
that's what Kermit is for me he's a cute
boy and then he cries for two days
straight and he's suddenly not so cute
it's this weird
it's this weird magic turkey does I
don't know what it is no it's not even
it's like charming even it's just
annoying it's so much oh sorry bud dad
called you annoying when's your next
tattoo I'm not getting another tattoo
why not I didn't even like plan on
getting the first two tattoos that I
have okay so when know November don't
want anymore didn't know I didn't want
any to begin with I love tattoos I think
they're so beautiful I just don't it
takes me too much to decide on something
I would want so I'm like I don't care
I'm going to stick and poke now I don't
want to do stick and poke looking
nightmare sick invoke that - I don't how
people decide on something yeah I do
I mean all it takes is you to do it once
and then you hopefully like it and
you're like oh it was easy I'll just do
it again and then you realize there's a
lot of space on your body mm-hmm
what's your next tattoo I'm still
deciding but I have a couple ideas in my
brain tell us why don't I don't know I'm
ready to be a secret secret huh all
right I'm gonna get a picture
photorealism I mean Sponge Bob from the
back with his pants pulled down so you
see his little sponge but right here on
my chest just the rear of Spongebob
Julien what I respect and support all of
your decisions but what the actual [ __ ]
that's a joke right why can't I get back
what can I get that is not really your
life I would get a spongebob tattoo of
his butt on your chest
have you seen have I seen what it's so
bright and round and squared his butt is
not SpongeBob SquarePants pants are
squares but it's not well how is that
possible
I don't know you gotta watch the show he
pulls down his pants and you just see
these two rings how is that possible all
right wait you see his butt on the show
for real I literally cannot tell what
you're joking about no because there's
gonna be some weird fan drawings just
like straight ass spongebob but
spongebob ass Toshi house right Toshi
Julian oh god it started playing a video
okay hello spongebob but let me see
that's square that is round yeah they're
like cheeks at the bottom sort of but
like why does his pants open like a
panel from the back like an electrical
box I'm gonna get this tattooed Julian
please no why it's terrible it's pretty
great I mean we'll talk about later
after I get it but that's my next one
do you God is your boy Jenna no don't
listen to its you boy listen to my
prayer you know I know what what do I
know sick of me what do I know
you know what do I know what did you
have to do - but - mmm
are you it's all of your serious or not
guess I'll find out Julian what why you
speak to me in riddles when the answer
to that is ready it will present itself
are you tattooing around double cheeked
up on a Thursday afternoon but on your
chest or not I'm not tattooing it we're
loopy aren't we I'm so tired
what do we do yesterday super [ __ ]
white cause that's why yeah there there
were there wait no laws yesterday that's
Pratt that's past hasn't past present
tense stop talking no that's past tense
of eight
wait no there wait no it's like there
weren't any there wasn't any laws wait
no laws we drank white yesterday no wait
no Clause we are out of it we are not
humans I mean we drank of we started
doing you like three because super well
start at three we're like hey let's
drink some we close and then
today we're both just zombies I'm a
zombie I'm an absolute Dombey I can't
just like drink during the day and not
have severe consequences do you remember
when we could just try and turn the day
and then wake up and everything was
chilling
yeah I'm not chilling today I'm not
chilling today it's like us it's like
sleepy - it's like you can't get untie
'red yeah hoo boy
you know you know listen to the mic yeah
but that was my coffee that it brought
up here and you've been slurping on it
stop okay again of the rest enjoy
everyone just unsubscribe
everyone just unsubscribe but I thought
you were about to leave me like almost
nothing in here no there's more than
nothing
wait
if you were an apple product what would
you be like a technology if you were an
apple product yes I'd be a dongle I
ain't no I'd be three dongles dongle
together because you don't have the
right port so you need a dongle one into
the other Donal and do the other dog
into the court I'd be a triple Bongo
I'd be an iPod shuffle
really I thought it'd be a charger
thanks babe what what kind of charger
it's a high-powered one the one that's
you know charging you up nice and fast I
just mean that because if you forget
your charger you're a bad planner and
you're the best planner I know so you'd
be the charger you always have the
charger if you are the charger ladies no
what do you think you would be I just
said an iPod shuffle that's what you
think you'd be the little square one
yes the one that looks like that yes
it's tiny yeah why would you be an iPod
stuff I would be an iPod shuffles not
how your brain works
yes you just have a bunch of ideas and
you press go and it shuffles through the
ideas yes
engineering in style yes
not what color teal all right number one
podcast on iTunes baby oh yeah why well
color would you be as a dongle I'd be
white they only make them in way unless
they're the aftermarket ones red Donald
Oh
aftermarket dongho aftermarket and
straight from Amazon do you think they
dongle or nah they'd be dangling do they
be dongle they do be dongle in we're
doing a nonsense podcast
Ananse cast they do be dong go and say
it they do be down boys um do you want
to know what I what did the mannequin
what did the life-sized doll say after
dinner what man I'm poly full cuz they
have polyfill inside of them you said
that because there's polyfill right
there that's good there's a good joke
though that is still in this room those
two boxes of polyfill are still here
from my jeans chair video who wants them
raise your hand alright you get it
contest is over what you just asked me
before I told that joke
nothing oh that was like that ready when
the principal would call my mom in front
of me and they were going this and just
look at me did you ever get in trouble
no I never went to the principal's
office that's not true you definitely
got what the hell I never not once went
to the principal's office uh because
they wanted me there I went there you
know I never got called to the
principal's office I was a good boy I
actually in middle school detention
scared me so much because you basically
the way I worked at our school was you
could get a 15 a 30 or a referral which
is 15 minutes attention 30 minutes
attention or 45 minutes and oh right up
which is the roof
and I think I only got a referral once
but it was wasn't even really my fault I
was just scared of it I'd never wanted
to get in trouble so I did I wasn't bad
what just thinking tell us what you're
thinking I was thinking about like the
one time that I got in trouble when I
was like a little little what you do
it's I can't remember if I told it on
the podcast or not but it was like
completely ridiculous
but I remember being a kid and being
like this is fine me and my best friend
I might almost say her name but like she
we lived on the same street like dogs
her what the [ __ ] dude no we were like
best buddies yeah and I think it was in
like first grade we are so excited that
we are in the same class together and
there was a little reading corner in the
back of the room and like we were we're
kind of weird kids yeah two of us yeah
it's why we got along so well yeah and
we were sitting in the back of the room
in like the reading corner and we're
like sitting like this with our legs
crossed like facing each other hmm and
for some reason we just like God in our
head that we were gonna take turns
pinching each other's face just be like
wow but like leave nail marks you know
II mean so she would do one on me and
I'd be like ah Dan that's a good one and
then she's like all right do me do me so
then I would pinch her face and she's
like oh and I'm like oh that was a good
one okay now you do me and we were just
sitting i just vividly remember hitting
each other city but like we were in pain
we I don't know why we did this no I you
know without you said middle school or
elementary no like first grade first
grade well we did that [ __ ] in middle
school but it's like the same idea yeah
you're like you're hurting each other
but like you're kind of doing it for fun
and you're like laughing you're more
curious about it yeah weird we weren't
really best buddies weren't trying to
hurt each other at all you know but all
of a sudden the teacher comes back there
was like what the hell are you guys to
discover that like what six in first
grade oh my just like to six-year-olds
in the back of the room pinching the
absolute [ __ ] out of each other's faces
it's like what what are you guys doing
so she sent us both to the principal's
office and she was like you know what
what did what did this girl do to you
that you guys pinched each other we're
like nothing like we're we're best
friends like what you shot we were just
hears having fun pinching each other day
weren't stimulated enough by class
[Laughter]
remember they had like sort of separated
us for the day to like figure out you
know if we were actually like the
investigation yeah yeah yeah and I just
see her in her whole face just covered
like in Vaseline gone to the nurse and
she's just like how's it going on this
you all dad it's like good to see you in
my face is like coverage is bad lately
yeah that's sick yeah that's so weird I
love it though I love it is that not so
weird no it's it's I mean kids are just
like curious and weird like that like we
used to play ABC game where we would
scratch each other's like skin off on
table Rihan and literally just account
to the ABCs and see what would happen
and then we played quarters where you
would put your hand on the ground on the
table and you would go bad like swipe it
into someone's knuckle and basically
make them bleed and you play blood you
know it goes where you just punched each
other that is the most cro-magnon game I
could think of that kids play let me
punch each other's fists you're punching
they're punchers like it is so
knuckle-dragging it is like so primitive
it's like the kids doing a lobster and
pinching into their lobsters claws as
hard as you can with your lobster claw
and you would like bleed and like hurt
yourself is like we're having fun man
I do remember like we would give each
other like rope burns and stuff and like
we would call it Rose Garden it's like
essentially the same thing where you
just like you take your fingers and you
pinch somebody and like scratch like a
road like the thorns in a rose well
because the point is at the end of the
game you it's like a whole story right
so you go like this you're like you
won't play Rose Garden you're like sure
so I push your sleeve up and I start
telling you about how I'm like telling
the land and like planting the seeds and
like really
like now I'm going over it with like a
rake and then the you're supposed to sit
there I like being so much pain then
they're like and now you have a rose
guard and you look down your arm it's
like a whole [ __ ] red you never did
that no I never do that it's called Rose
Garden that sounds with that game I did
like I don't think about that ever like
as an adult looking back here like we
were just trying to hurt each other
apparently yeah we always thought it was
so funny and so fun it's funny I want it
I like want to know more about the
psychology behind my kids do that
because it's not like it's not like you
know you have to you have to be dealing
with some issues or even psychological
trauma or anything like that to do that
you're just a normal kid who's curious
and wants to [ __ ] do it you learn like
well I mean feel like six like I was in
first grade but even me and middle squad
and there was no sense of any of like
the problems just doing it for fun it
was literally just for fun yeah I know
I'm saying like if you're a kid or even
a teenager and you haven't like
experienced a certain threshold of pain
no it's sort of just exciting as in
anything else you have an experience
before that's true that's like when we
were six and we were pinching each
other's faces it's sort of like what
what type of pain is that and like what
will happen it's kind of funny
yeah I'm hurting you are you okay no oh
you're good okay we're good pinch me now
yeah you're just doing experiments how
much what does that feel like how much
pain do you know what does it feel like
yeah I don't know you want to Rose
Garden no please no Rose Garden do you
wanna play ABC game what is that you
never play another scratch skin you take
the like your thumb nail and you lightly
you're not doing it hard but you you
basically I think you like scratch while
they say the ABCs mm-hmm and you get all
the way to Z and then you're like okay
your turn and then they go and then
after like the third or fourth time
you're like busting through the skin
here either it was that or you actually
wrote the letters I forget which one it
was maybe you wrote the letters with
your thumbnail but you're basically just
like ripping up the top of your skin on
your hand
truly special stuff that's it that's it
that's the game that is the game hey
boring
Oh says the girl literally just pinching
her friend's face we were having a good
time so were we playing the ABC game and
it was educational did you say your
ABC's I also will never forget I think
it was like you know my mom or whatever
they're like why did you guys do that
we're like we were we were just playing
yeah what's wrong with you guys you know
nice to do it like sit around and pinch
each other's faces yeah mom yeah each
other's face you know he's do a lot Oh
what does this surprise you want to draw
all over my body with pens yeah that
didn't surprise all over my body all of
my arms all of my legs all my hands I
literally would write on my hands every
single day in class just everywhere I
wrote on my hands a lot but it was like
to remember to do stuff same but also to
not also just nonsense it was a mix of
everything I wasn't really much of like
a doodler though like I doodled a little
bit but like I didn't I wasn't one of
those people that had all these like
lovely doodles cuz I was just bad at it
you can't be bad at doodling yes you can
no you can't can you I beg to differ is
it possible to be bad at pre value
doodling but doodling is likes it's
subjective it's like you're just
literally your minds like not even
thinking interesting or whatever you
mean like some people's doodles look
really nice and yours don't is
everything if I were to quote-unquote
doodle it would be a scribble so it's
just a scribble that's beautiful I don't
think so it is okay
marvel do you want to go
what oh yeah I did a whole time
he asked me that I was trying to but
then you silently shook my hand and then
asked Marvel a question yes I'd you
don't on my body and all my papers I
have to sneeze i don't want to sneeze
though don't worry serious look at the
light no look at the light no look at
the light it makes you sneeze I said I
don't want to sneeze why would you do
that why sneeze that's gone sometimes in
Jenna's about a sneeze I'll say bless
you before she sneezes I guess so man
you should try that you should try that
with someone like your roommate or
significant others I'm about to sneeze
they're going like just go bless you and
then look at you don't sneeze it's funny
for me Congrats on your next sneeze
whenever that happens thank you sneeze
sneeze now knees you breathe on me you
know you really tap your nose do I ever
see your eyes water and like sneeze you
know no but I have heard of staring like
at light yeah looking up and looking at
light yeah that means you're allergic to
the Sun no it doesn't doesn't it not are
you saying well there's hours different
types of allergies right looking up into
the Sun makes you sneeze you're allergic
to the Sun I that's that's logic yeah
thanks for coming into this week science
talk we'll be back next week stop
drinking all my coffee
remember the book fair Book Fair was fun
book fair was like really lit actually
they had posters they had books the N I
just like the Calvin and Hobbes and I
liked any of the books that were like
about arts and crafts like craft books
yeah I loved Calvin and Hobbes and
crafts books we would have been friends
think like we are now little been
friends because we both were doing
nothing but PE and PE yeah we loved PE
in fact I didn't never change out of my
PE clothes for the most of my meals yeah
we're aware PE clothes either free
clothes what do you mean you don't have
to worry about you know where just where
your PE clothes gonna make a comment we
didn't get pretty close you have P
universe no we brought our own to school
nerds
what why we nerds it was just like
change for gym so we would bring our own
shorts our own pants or how did you even
know who was a student who was the
teacher you're all wearing different
things Julian what the hell you got
uniform they really shitty like dollar
store shorts and like this grey shirt
that we literally would Sharpie your
name on the shirt where it said like
Lincoln PE weren't there like 4000
people in your school not in my middle
school 4000 kids in a middle school
[Laughter]
middle school I don't even know I could
look it up but it you know it was a big
school as public school but it wasn't
for 4000 was my high school yeah
thousand EGP school clothes in high
school and do pee in high school because
I played sports you either played sports
or did BT wasn't see that's garbage
because when I was in high school we had
to do gym every year that's and we could
only opt out one semester of one year
why cuz PE is such an important topic to
be educated on no that was the choice if
you're in a varsity sport you can opt
out one quarter not even semester
quarter you could opt out one quarter of
the year out of PE we didn't get to just
not do PE because we'd it's for yes it
was sports or PE I think I did one
semester of PE and there was only reason
was because it was the fall semester of
my freshman year and baseball hadn't
started yet and so then once it hit like
January I was like done with PE because
I was only baseball from then on and
because you know like you would you play
a sport you play basketball baseball
football tennis whatever then you
wouldn't have to do PE but then people
also would do the thing where they would
do like independent
where they would some of them were legit
and some of them were full of [ __ ] where
you would basically say I actually say I
golf or I do something it's off-campus I
grant you to do this activity and it's
not here and you would have your coach
like wherever that is like sign this
like sheet every week and that's what
that was your PE if you were like a
person the rode horses play golf without
a golf teammate yours right yeah like
sports that didn't exist at school
that's garbage so we just we all had to
take gym and if you were in a varsity
sport you could opt out one quarter that
was it we didn't get to just be like
yeah well I'm physically active
somewhere else in fact we had a rule in
our school that if if you know I was 16
years old and I skipped gym class that
day for whatever reason you're not
allowed to participate in your game
leader but why why would they need you
if you're already participating in a
sport with like practice and
conditioning and whatever why would they
need you to like spend more of your time
that's already now limited because you
play a sport that's in a PE class it's a
class it's the same as skipping any
other class what was your PE class like
what do you I don't know all kinds of
stuff because I don't like basically 0
PE experience in high school so I don't
know what it well so I think if I recall
correctly we would usually have like a
couple of choices so like you for your
fall PE you know there might be days
when you go in and they're like alright
we're just playing soccer or so just get
in there and go play a game of soccer
yeah but you know since you're with
everybody from all kinds of grades and
all kinds of different physical
abilities it's just about participating
you don't have to like be incredibly
good at soccer yeah sure yeah but
there's plenty of people that just sit
on the bleachers and say I'm I'm not
participating today and then the teacher
gives you an F for that day or whatever
and so you just you change your clothes
and just go and try your best but that
like it wasn't always like that some
days it was like literally orang2
orienteering
we're like you read a map and like go
walk around outside walking we did
gymnastics we did golf we did square
dancing was everyone's literally
everyone's favorite unit and gym you're
talking to all high school here right
yeah
because like everyone loved to just go
to gym class some some of us would give
very into it and bring our own plaid
shirts and it was just the derpiest way
to participate in physical activity it's
fun you get to dance
really stupid how many great time I'm
not calling square dancing stupid I'm
saying when you're 16 and your choices
would you would you like to go play
soccer or would you like to square dance
I'm like give me that mole [ __ ]
hoedown beach it's time to get it poppin
interesting that's interesting I've
never actually really thought about it
so like you were a serious athlete like
in your high school when you played
softball right like I was prime their
primary sport I played three sports a
year though and I'm only allowed to opt
out one quarter it was varsity all year
yeah no I get it but I don't get to just
skip gym all year for sure Mike my
question is as a serious athlete who is
like focused on your sport you played in
college so you were focused in high
school yeah did you ever get to the
point as like a junior or senior where
you were like man I have a big game this
afternoon I've double header this
afternoon I have games all week I've
been training hard I'm sore and I gotta
go to PE did you like that I mean it
would have been nice like everyone's
looking forward to the quarter that they
get to opt out of gym because now we
would have a free period and said
because you don't have an empty period
without yeah but you're like most people
save it like I was saving it for my
second semester or SEC like last quarter
of my senior year no for sure that's
like that would be nice but gym class
was easy it was just like go and walk
around the track that's fair plus your
gym teacher knows like who the student
athletes are and the point of gym class
was never to like physically push people
yeah okay like if you're if you're doing
basketball the point isn't to have
everybody you like be leave their sweaty
it's like you might spend a day just
dribbling yeah okay no you're just
exposed to like sports and exposing them
to moving their body for about 40
minutes a day it's not it wasn't
physically taxing so no let me I looked
forward to gym probably more than most
of my other classes because at least I
was doing something fun and a lot of
times like our gym teacher was super
cool and just
let us crack jokes and mess around the
whole time fair enough
I loved weightlifting when everyone
would just go in there and they will all
get on the abductor and adductor so just
sit there and [ __ ] die laughing at
each other like it's stuff like that you
know yeah yeah I get that the point is
for 40 minutes we're not getting in
there and seriously lifting weights
they're just like showing like exposing
people to it and moving for a little bit
sure
yeah so no that's a good that's a that's
a good way to put it I didn't have
really thought about like that but
that's cool I mean it's like it makes it
makes sense especially if maybe you were
to plea like you maybe you played tennis
right and then you know one day at PE
you were playing football and you would
have never played football if it weren't
for that guy so you're kind of exposing
people this is see this is exactly how I
knew that I was never gonna succeed at
tennis because tennis was one of our
sports and your spring
I couldn't stop losing all the balls cuz
I was hitting them out of the out of the
thing classic softball teacher was like
you have to point your racket down I was
like I'm swinging for the fences I hit a
home run we talking about so I'm just
full-blown like I used to play times
with my grandfather a lot and that's
whatever due to because it was like
bombs yes then you just know like that's
never gonna be sport for me probably
racket sport this is fun maybe actually
I think you would be good at tennis I
know would be good at tennis if I
stopped hitting it out of the way yeah
thing the record court yeah the racquet
court thing what did you ever play any
other sports that you would have never
touched like did you ever do golf or
anything like that yeah we did golf how
is that so great but I played golf with
my dad well that's cool all right like a
flag football basketball mm-hmm
terrible at both of those things that's
what gave him oh I'm a lot better at
like flag football than basketball
balls fun very very very very very very
very hold on I'm not done yet very bad
at basketball Oh
what position did you play in flag
football that you liked I don't the run
and grab someone elses flag position
nice
yeah up top I was much better at
catching the ball then throwing cotton
see your receiver or defensive enemy I
was also small and fast not so much
anymore
are you cute thank you alright sick I
can't believe you just didn't have to go
to gym coz you played baseball you
missed out on a lot of laughs and good
times let me tell you that I'd
absolutely miss out on laughs and good
times I was suffering while they made us
climb like Apes down the Greek Theatre
to condition us for baseball we had rock
climbing we also had gymnastics yeah I
would if I could have Joe like chosen to
do PE you know in lieu of some of the
conditioning we had super baseball that
would've been like [ __ ] yeah
I'll throw a football around instead of
like actually puke my brains out because
this is such an exhausting workout what
was really fun was sometimes you're
broken up into like girls and boys so
like there'd be all girls which is nice
for some stuff and then some of them
would be like co-ed you know so I'm
pretty sure like gymnastic square
dancing was a co-ed unit so every you
got to be in there with boys which was
super fun yeah cuz you're like I'm just
here to hang out with the boy that I
like which happened all the time well
[ __ ] door what and some like I think
gymnastics was co-ed - so there was it
was a really good time that's cool
watching boys do log rolls and get an F
in gymnastics mocking them boys joke - I
mean I'm joking - I'm literally always
joking um I want to go to gym I I play
baseball that's rude actually that was
toxic that was toxic don't act like you
wouldn't have like if you were a
softball player in your senior year and
you like you know you're kind of a stud
right like you're gonna waste your time
in PE like come on I didn't say it I was
waste of time I always thought it was
one of the best periods of the day what
if you like hurt yourself on the day of
a big game in PE
I don't know I I don't think I'd be that
upset obviously you have to be really
what about your coaches Julianne you'd
have to be really sure coaches hey
Julian you would have to be really
trying to hurt yourself and p.i things
happen no they really make it so like
your it's not alright it's just about
learning and moving your body it's not
about like physically exerting so no I
know I know but things happen mmm you
know my feet are falling asleep because
they won't stop singing okay oh we can
call it there let's just call it let's
throw in the towel my guru me anyway
thank you guys for listening to us talk
about tattoos and PE PE be like man I
wish I could find a picture of me and my
PE clothes you can see what they look
like they were sick yeah I was like the
one a I could always count on to keep my
GPA soaring me too up high up high the
opposite where my GPA was somebody with
your punch with your punch of guys don't
play by your bloody knuckles it's not
safe and if your kid comes home with
bloody knuckles just tell them to quit
punching each other's puncher
what you do you punch somebody's punch
or when you puncher oh well you guys
have a wonderful week sorry the podcast
is late this week we appreciate your
patience and we'll see you next week on
the next episode of ghent podcast bye
[Music]
[Music]